Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday Day,
June 10th,
2013 happy birthday to me.
Happy Birthday to me.
Happy Birthday.
You ran.
Uh,
okay.
Happy Birthday to me.
Okay.
Yeah.
What's going on?
Oh,
sorry.
Just yelled there.
I'm excited.
This is the first time I've been doing,
I've been doing this podcast
for six years and not once has the part I have the podcasting God's ever graced,
meet with the podcasts.
That actually fell on my birthday and I'm going to go out on a limb here and I'm
going to say despite the fact that there were over 7,458 podcasts on my street
alone,
I that I am the first podcaster to have a host of fucking podcast on his
birthday.
I'm putting that out there.
All right.
You can go with Wikipedia,
Google it,
or do whatever the fuck you want to do with it.
I'm telling you,
I'm the first one who ever did it.
These other guys and women who said that they did it,
they're just talking.
All right.
That's just talk over there.
I'm actually fucking doing it.
MMM.
So I don't want you to thinking right now you like,
wow,
bill,
it's your birthday.
First question everybody asks,
how old are you now?
I'm 45
let me tell you something about the fives for all you youngsters out there.
It's not the ones,
it's not the tools.
It's not the sevens.
It's the fives.
The fives get ya.
You know what I mean?
and now 24 kinds of scares,
but 25 fuck.
Here we go.
Slide near the 30 you know that's when you're,
you're right on top of the fence there,
right?
The fucking Berlin Wall.
You know?
Which way am I going to fall?
Free side or the countryside,
right?
Aging is like,
it's like reverse progress.
So you would actually,
when you get to the fives,
you fall back over into fucking a post World War II.
Yeah,
sure.
Well,
I guess from now until forever,
it's going to be post World War II.
Bill,
what do you know what the fuck I'm talking about?
Whenever they put up that God damn wall,
what did they put it up?
They put it up during a Kennedy.
Oh was it 1948.
Oh,
is that Israel?
I don't fucking remember.
Um,
35 was a bitch.
They all suck.
I'm not going to lie to you if they all suck,
but 35 was a bitch and now 45,
five I'm sliding into 50.
Does that even make sense?
I'm still doing pull ups.
How can I be 45 what?
I'm still doing polyps.
That doesn't make any fucking sense.
Cause when I was a kid,
old people,
nobody,
actually,
nobody worked out when I was a kid.
Yeah,
nobody's strapped.
Like I've never seen.
My Dad tried to touch his toes my entire fucking life.
I never seen him do a jumping jack.
I never saw any of his friends.
None of them.
They just rolled out of bed,
you know,
sat on the side of the bed for a second going,
ha ha.
And then they get up,
brush your teeth,
take a shower,
put on some clothes,
have bacon and eggs and go out to work,
you know,
like fucking come home.
Okay.
They walked through the door and be like,
all right,
cool.
And everybody would shut the fuck up.
And then they'd sit down and they eat their fucking beef stew and then they go
in the living room and they'd sit down in their chair.
I had
fucking tired.
What,
what'd you do today,
Billy?
Listen,
I'm tired.
Okay.
All right.
Just go to your room.
You know,
and then they'd watch a little bit TV right now within two hours they have
fucking head was just bad.
All right.
And that was that day.
There was no working out whatsoever.
There was maybe like two people who could do still do pull ups at 45 when I was
a kid and it was like Johnny Weissmuller and uh,
that guy who did the juicer,
who used to dress like Arthur funds a rally when he worked on cars on happy
days.
I want to three o'clock.
Um,
hey,
do you know stuff?
Did I tell you this?
I actually,
uh,
I can't remember it cause I did that,
that quick podcast in middle of the week I did an episode of a Nick Kroll show.
And I got to work with Ron Howard's dad and he was,
yeah,
he was in cool hand Luke.
And he actually told me stories about being in the,
uh,
I guess he's in,
he had a small role and he's in the last scene.
We're cool hand Luke.
Um,
for those of you who haven't seen it yet,
spoiler alert.
All right.
Sticky rice
fingers in your ears and go
for the next fucking 10 seconds.
All right.
Because I don't want to hear your shit.
Um,
and at the end of the movie when cool hand Luke gets shot in the church,
uh,
he's part of the cops,
you know,
that had taken them out.
And then that what we've got here,
that guy says no,
we'll take them from here.
He's in that scene.
Um,
absolutely legendary.
And he said they shot it up in Bakersfield,
California.
So there you go.
And the guy was hilarious.
I think it was like 85 years old improv and still sharp as hell.
Um,
it was awesome.
Great,
great guy.
So thanks to a crawl show in Nick Kroll.
Forget me on,
cause if he didn't,
I wouldn't have had that experience.
And please watch the Kroll show cause I think that dude's a fucking genius.
They go,
there's my plug for the look of that on my birthday.
Hyping somebody else's project.
You know what that is it right.
That isn't right at all.
It's very generous.
Why being a martyr bill,
Huh?
Don't cry for me.
Fucking Billy.
Um,
I'm going to,
I'm going to hype something right now.
Hey Bill,
nobody stopping you.
It's just stupid podcasts.
I'll right
fucking grumpy cunt.
Um,
tickets for the Billy red state tour are now on sale,
uh,
for a number of the venues.
Uh,
specifically,
uh,
my first two dates,
one in Boise,
Idaho,
and the other one in Bozeman.
Hope I'm saying that right.
Montana,
the last state in the union that I've never been to.
Um,
and here's the deal.
You know,
a lot of east coast comics,
like myself,
we never traveled the states unless we're doing some college gig or some shit,
but we usually don't come through here.
So it would be great if you guys gave me some wonderful stories to tell all my
fucking hilarious comedian friends about where to go to play,
you know,
Hi Montana.
You want the sensation,
the teen idol cessation,
Joe Fucking Derosa to grace big sky country within goddammit,
sell a pair,
your wrangler jeans,
get off the Meth,
whatever.
You got to fucking do it.
Come down to my shop.
I'm just fucking with you guys.
I'm,
I'm just hoping that I'm going to sell tickets out there.
What it really is and I'm nervous that I'm not going to,
which is why I'm already trying to guilt you guys into the fact that I'm going
to spread rumors that you guys don't like East Coast comics even though I'm a
Hollywood sell out out here.
Um,
so anyways,
that's the deal.
The Billy red state tour is coming to a state near you,
make stops in Idaho,
Montana,
South Dakota,
obscure places in Colorado.
I don't have the dates in front of me,
Kansas,
Oklahoma,
and uh,
El Paso,
Texas is where it wraps up.
And uh,
we'd love to see you.
I'm working on a Badass tee shirt that I'm going to be selling.
Um,
it's selling only on the,
on the red red state tour and a,
and that's it.
All right,
there you go.
I'm done plugging the shit.
So let's get onto this movie that I wanted to see until I saw the rating.
And now it's fucking annoying.
The shit out of me is,
uh,
you know,
it's this summer season.
You know,
there's actually a wonderful movie coming up called the heat that a certain
someone might be in.
If you watch the,
uh,
the trailer,
the heat starring Sandra Bullock and Muscle Melissa McCarthy,
if you guys could hook me up and go buy a movie ticket to that one,
uh,
that would be tremendous.
And,
uh,
you know,
be something that I would enjoy.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Is it any wonder why they don't have me do press for anything?
Where the Fuck Brad Pitt?
I'm looking this up right now.
Or Z.
What is the name of this fucking movie?
Okay.
World War Z.
Oh,
there we go.
Now here's a fucking movie.
Here's a guy.
There's a fucking movie that I wanted to see.
Okay.
Brad Pitt,
World War Z,
and to the fucking world,
right?
Okay.
The zombies.
This she shit the world as we know it will not exist in,
I don't know how many days.
One of the great fucking lines,
the kind of line that makes me want to get off my fucking couch,
you know,
put on my slippers.
Yeah.
Put on a smoking jacket and go down to the local movie theater and taking a
picture.
Right?
And then at the end of it,
if they show everybody running for their fucking lives,
it's the end of the God damn world.
Okay.
World War z.
What?
What did,
I don't even know what that is.
It was World War One.
World War Two.
They said,
fuck all the numbers right through infinity.
Fuck the entire alphabet all the way to the last letter.
World War Z.
I'm a,
I'm fucking,
I'm there.
I got to see this shit.
And then in the end,
what do they do to me?
Rated PG 13 oh,
go fuck yourself.
All right.
And that's not a go fuck yourself to Brad Pitt or the director or anybody else
that I'm trying not to burn a bridge with.
It's a fuck you to the conch.
I know that that was a rated r movie.
In fact,
I've heard that it was and they fucking took the knees out of it and they
fucking drag it down and to PG 13 all right,
I don't give a fuck who you are.
If the world is ending and you're getting chased by zombies,
you're not running around going,
oh golly gee,
oh heck crime.
And he's Oh,
Jimminy cricket.
And once every 10 minutes you go,
ah,
Shit.
Okay.
You know
you don't.
That's the end of the world was zombies from the beginning.
Once they discover these zombies to the end of that movie where they hopefully
solve the problem,
should be a bunch of people.
Wait,
eight 85% of the people going,
fuck what the fuck?
And then the other 50% should be grabbing them by the shoulders gone for,
I said,
get a fucking all the ESL.
Right.
That should be most of the dialogue in that movie.
But now,
now I don't know why I just said it that way.
Now it's,
it's PG 13.
So what are they going to do?
What,
what,
what's going to happen?
And they're going to slowly,
you know,
have some for why we should not stop using fucking plastic water bottles.
So they get a weave that into the storyline.
You know,
you know,
it's funny,
I actually tweeted,
I have to admit that I hang my head in shame,
but I did tweet and I do still consider myself a man even saying that out loud.
Say it again,
Bill.
I tweeted,
um,
I said,
Zombie movies are rated R Hashtag World War Z,
right?
And most people agreed.
So of course this one client goes,
I have to respectfully disagree,
said the success of a,
the walking dead.
That's what he said.
Said the success of the walking dead fucking Twitter.
Heck,
it's just like,
oh,
that,
that's,
that's a great idea.
I see that business model.
So let me get this straight.
I'm going to spend over a fucking a hundred $150 million of my money making a
Zombie movie and I'm going to make it no more fucking crazier than what people
can sit at home on their couch and watch.
That's what the fuck you telling me.
That's that right there.
That's your business model.
That makes sense to you.
Forget about all the clients who are going to steal the movie anyways,
or just,
man,
I'll just wait a few weeks and then I'll watch it on fucking whatever.
Right?
You want to get them out.
You'll want to get them excited.
Say That,
come down and go see the picture and a big screen.
That's themselves.
Some popcorn.
Sit now with their best gout.
Right?
You're going to make it.
You know what?
Why don't you just make,
according to Jim's World War Z,
nope.
No disrespect to Jim or according,
right.
I'm just saying what?
What the fuck?
What is the purpose?
It's like when you go out to your favorite pizza place.
If you could make the pizza just as good at home,
you wouldn't fucking go out there.
Or if someone would just show up to your fucking house and step out of your TV,
go,
here's your fucking pizza.
You're not going,
why the fuck would you make a PG 13 Zombie fucking movie?
Could somebody for the love of fucking God explained that to me?
They've been doing that lately.
Alright.
Superhero movies should also be rated r unless you're doing one of those Doshi
ones that nobody cares about.
All right?
But all the other ones,
Batman,
Captain America,
all that Shit should all be rated r those superheroes are not for kids.
Those are for adults who don't know how to fight and want to live through
somebody else who actually has a six pack.
That's what those movies are for.
I feel,
you know,
then I actually think that I would take it.
I would actually go for,
if I haven't made a fucking superhero movie,
I would go for the NC 17
get out me.
If you remember in Spiderman when he's hanging upside down and the fucking girls
kissing him,
right?
That wouldn't be,
he would have been hanging a little bit lower,
if you know what I mean.
He'd still be down,
but he would be hanging a little bit lower.
Come on people do the math.
Okay.
Somewhere between 68 and 70 is what I'm talking about.
All right.
That's how that fucking scene would have gone down.
Okay.
And fuck all these critics.
Who would be like,
oh my God,
that's absolutely horrific.
Stan Lynch must be fucking rolling over on his futon cause they never gave him
the money deserve for creating the character.
And I,
I would,
I stand by it.
This is the Peter Parker that everyone knew existed,
but no one wanted to see.
You know he'd be hanging upside down just stores soon as fucking spider Dick
right in your mouth.
Okay.
You know why?
Cause he's,
cause he's spider man.
All right.
Half man,
half spider.
Using the power for good and he still has a day job.
Still has a fucking day job and that great.
We taught what a what a common man.
He's not like Bruce Wayne walking around at all these fucking eyes wide shut
party.
You know how many Tuxedos does Bruce Wayne.
Okay.
And how did he make his money?
You know,
I know all these comic book people of Losing Their fucking minds cause I don't
know anything about the backstory,
but any of these fucking people,
I don't give a shit.
All right.
How much,
what,
what did he do?
How did he inherit money when both his parents got shot in the alley?
Dad,
they're,
your parents got killed.
Is that what the money's spent it,
he's never working.
Yeah.
He's never at work in any of those fucking movies.
It's always going over to the mayor's house.
He's a fucking trust fund kid.
Yeah.
Beat a park is still works for the school paper or whatever.
Ah,
working for fucking Jamison,
a guy named after whiskey.
Alright.
Techy guy.
And I liked when he wore the black suit too.
I think that that one look better,
you know,
and the suits started controlling him.
I didn't like that.
That made Peter Look weak.
All right.
You know,
you know,
I'm in over my fucking head when I'm,
I'm talking about God damn superheroes here.
Um,
all right,
what are we doing here?
17 minutes in and it's time.
It's time to talk to you about how you can shave better.
Everybody.
I like the light.
Doing the shaded ones just makes me feel like the old days,
like when you used to watch baseball and everything was about you fucking balls
or Cologne,
right?
Or Busan,
aqua velvet,
old spice.
Put it on your nuts,
right?
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody get a good shave.
Getting a good shave can be a real pain in the aish.
Searching around through 50 different brands.
Matching new blades to old handles.
Bullshit features where your razor doubles as a flashlight.
Vibrator.
Toothpick.
20 bucks for a new razor.
It's a complete rip off.
I talked to you guys about this.
They have the stupid blades locked behind glass,
right?
Like their bars of gold.
You know,
why are people stealing them?
Cause they're a frigging rip off.
Alright,
frigging you can tell them to read an advertising.
They're even Carson in this,
in the copy here.
So to hell with it,
it's a fucking rip off.
20 bucks for a new razor to hell with that.
Got a dollar shave.com to get high quality razors delivered to your door for
just a couple of bucks a month.
They,
they've made it so simple to get high quality hundred percent guaranteed fucking
razors set on schedule so you never have to think about it ever again.
Every month you get a new pack.
Every week you change your blade,
alright?
And it's,
it costs a fraction of what you pay at retail.
All right?
I want you,
I want you to try it.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward Slash burr.
You'll get a free sample of Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter,
which is awesome with a,
your first shipment also makes the perfect father's day gift,
the dollar Shave Club,
something he can actually use.
All right?
Would you like to watch TV a little bit better everybody?
Would you like to watch it more efficiently?
We'll I got something for you.
He says,
pointing at you with his freckled index finger,
Hulu Plus Hulu plus.
Um,
you've tried streaming hit shows on your PC,
on hulu.com.
Now it's time to start your free trial of exclusive content.
In your living room and on your mobile devices on Hulu plus.
This is why I love this thing.
You can actually watch it on your,
your,
your smartphone,
wherever the hell you go on your tablet,
I believe is what they say.
Hey Bill,
why don't you just read the copy?
Okay.
With Hulu plus you get total control to watch thousands of shows wherever you,
wherever you want,
whenever you want.
Use Hulu plus on connected TV's,
game consoles,
Blu ray players,
Roku,
apple TV,
PC,
or watch from anywhere on your smartphone or tablet on demand at all times and
with Hulu plus you can binge on full seasons.
What's your favorite current shows and even full series runs of classic TV
shows.
It's endless.
They got community monitored families Southpark,
SNL Monday night raw.
The man show Jimmy Kimmel,
family guy and more.
Hulu plus is only seven 99 a month.
Look at this.
You get blades delivered right to your house.
You got TV wherever you want.
It's unbelievable.
But right now they're offering an extended free trial of Hulu plus that is only
available to the podcast.
Listeners.
Take control of your TV watching experience.
Go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu plus banner
for your extended free trial,
or go to Hulu plus.com/bill again,
the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com or go to Hulu
plus.com/bill this right here,
Hulu plus.
This is the future.
It's just the way you're going to watch TV.
You only get to watch what you want to watch and you get to watch it when you
want to watch a righty.
There you go.
Okay.
Back to the podcast here.
Um,
with the folks to fucking put cast your current,
um,
oh,
here's a question somebody had.
Hey,
Bilbo Fagens.
Now people,
let's try to keep the homophobia down a little bit and he says,
I went to see your show in Denmark a couple of years ago or a year.
I don't fucking remember.
Are you going to do some more shows in Europe?
Preferably in Scandinavia.
Thanks.
A why?
Yes.
Yes I am.
I'm going to be coming over to Europe in the beginning of December.
Okay.
I'm going to go all Howard Dean here.
We're going to start in Ireland.
We're going to kind of on an angle and,
hey,
no,
we're gonna.
Uh,
I'm gonna Start in Ireland.
I bill,
I haven't looked at the date yet,
but I imagine I'm going to go to all the places that I've been to before and
maybe add another couple of cities,
but I'm going,
I'm hoping to go.
Ireland,
Scotland,
England,
Denmark,
Norway,
Sweden and Finland again.
And uh,
who knows.
Maybe I can add something else.
Maybe in a,
okay,
where the hell else could I go?
I know if you get too far south in Europe,
they start to like more,
they,
they're still on that Benny Hill Shit where they want us.
Yeah.
Way.
Bay Bay,
Bay,
Ba to day,
day to day.
They want to see that shit.
They're very intellect slapstick and prat falls.
I don't know if that's true.
I'm not trying to insult anybody in France,
you know,
Italy or whatever.
I heard you can get halfway through Germany,
you know.
Oh,
Amsterdam or Rotterdam or some of those places that have been to,
or some other places.
Maybe I could do some standup,
but I'd love to do it and I'm trying to keep up on what's going on over there,
over in Europe.
Wow.
What's going on over in Europe?
Everybody,
it's time for a new segment called what's going on in Europe,
delivered by an ignorant American.
Well,
evidently there's floods in Germany.
Okay.
On this river that goes all the way down to the Czech Republic.
And there they were moving people out.
And uh,
that story made me sick to my stomach just having water damage in my house.
I can't imagine an entire fucking river coming through my house.
So my condolences to everybody out there.
Uh,
Vladimir Putin is getting divorced from his fucking wife.
You know,
she doesn't like to be in the spotlight.
he likes going out there and lifting up little boy shirts and blowing bubbles on
this stomachs in front of the press.
That just to it.
If they've grown apart,
the kids are grown up.
They go in their separate ways.
I think,
um,
I think Latin mayor wants a nice hot piece of ass.
You know,
like in 2008,
they speculated that he was banging some chick.
I'm always going to marry some chick and a,
and as far as I could tell with my ignorance,
they put that paper out of business
and I have to tell you as fucked up as this country's becoming,
it's way better.
You know,
cause you don't have to deal with stuff like that.
Although I am a little disturbed with the Obama going to China to be like,
well,
hey,
how do you censor your,
your fucking,
how do you censor your people that you're supposed to be doing the right thing
for,
you know?
No,
no.
Say,
and there you go.
And that's what's going on in the world.
I know what's going on.
The word Turkey,
they have in those protests over there,
and I'll start it off with a bunch of hippies because they were cutting down
the,
uh,
the trees in the park and one to put up a strip mall and all the hippies and
Turkey.
We're like,
hey,
okay,
that's not cool.
Man,
it started with that shit and then all of a sudden everybody just snapped.
It was like,
by the way,
you know,
fuck the police and all this other shit.
I like you.
But up on that stuff lately I've been going to that Al Jazeera,
England,
English,
whatever,
which I was saying on the Wednesday,
the special one that I thought that the Al Jazeera and I know a lot of people
listen to it right now.
Like what are you a fucking terrorist?
That's what I thought cause low lately I've noticed Al Jazeera has been on like
your TV,
my TV's in like hotel rooms and I'm like,
what the fuck did they got this terrorist channel on here for?
Um,
and for those you oversee listening to this and laughing.
You have to understand that the only thing that we've seen,
mmm.
Unless you seek it out over here is when they would broadcast Americans getting
their heads sought off by,
uh,
you know,
al Qaeda.
That's the only thing we saw.
And the way they would frame it would be like,
and they actually tell a vlog channel.
So I just assumed that like that was like,
you don't,
like Ted Turner has TNT and TBS,
I thought a Saba bin Ladin with that oil money,
you know,
that was his t and t like Al Jazeera.
But uh,
she filed it really fucking interesting and it's great to see a,
I don't know,
it's just great to just read about other countries.
It's not,
it's not,
not,
you know,
it's not what you said.
I think it is.
And I'm not saying that they don't trash the u s but it's kind of interesting to
read the criticism,
to hear their perception of what's going on here next.
Saying that there are 100% right.
Not saying they're a hundred percent raw.
Oh well we get it.
You try to broaden your horizons.
Does that mean checking out that and somebody told me also checkout BBC World
and uh,
whatever.
I know they're all full of shit to some extent.
They all have their rangle but it's a,
you know,
you get enough angles,
this shit,
maybe you could stand in the middle of that shit storm.
I try to make sense of it.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
plus I'm hedging my bets,
you know,
from when the dollar collapses over here.
Hopefully at that point I could,
I could maybe,
uh,
then do a Billy red state tour over and fucking,
I dunno,
India,
I don't fucking know.
Speaking of which,
this is another great reason to go to Al Jazeera
cause he cause failures.
Americans who just think it's a terrorist thing.
They got some great stories here from around the world that you're not going to
hear about.
Here's one for you.
Referees sentence for sex bribe and Singapore.
Okay.
Oh,
Lebanese lineman pled guilty to accepting sexual favors in exchange for agreeing
to fix a football match.
That
why wouldn't you just get a walker?
You know,
why wouldn't you just,
it's just go look at some online porn.
Good Lord.
Go to a bar.
Say a load of somebody.
Okay.
How fucking lucky.
I mean,
I don't understand it.
I want to see what these guys look like.
But here's a story.
Three Lebanese football flares play football referees,
sorry.
At blood pled guilty to accepting free sex charges from a gambling linked global
syndicate and return for agreeing to rig a match with is Singapore Judge Jaylene
too.
And differing sentencing sentencing for a third.
The third guy just got a hand job or maybe he was a creep who just like to
watch,
um,
a district court judge on Monday,
jailed assistant referee a,
I'm not saying their fucking names.
Uh,
uh,
talk topic.
The first name Ali Abdallah.
He gave him three months
and then the third referee,
Ali,
another Ali Ali,
I think over there is,
that's like somebody named Mike,
at least back in the day before they started naming kids Dakota.
Um,
the assistant referees broke down into sobs.
When the judge Lau low,
we ping low.
We pay,
motherfucker said a,
they could be freed by later on Monday or Tuesday after remission for good
behavior and due to time already served a weighting their sentences,
they fucking broke down and cry.
Cried.
All right,
let me tell you something.
I don't know much.
I don't know much about going to prison,
but I know you don't want to fucking cry.
Okay.
Going into prison.
I don't think you want to do that.
I really don't.
Unless maybe they're crying because maybe they just dip putting them into the
regular jail with all the fucking rapist and that type of shit and I got to
somehow not get fucked in the ass until Monday or Tuesday.
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine the calories you would burn just by stressing that someone was
going to fucking rape you and the Goddamn booty hole?
You know what I mean?
I would just think the quivering alone would be like walking on a treadmill at
like,
you know,
3.1
um,
I don't want to get into that next year I had,
that was a rape joke,
right?
Is that fucking failed comic turned blog are going to give me shit about it.
You know,
I did comedy for a minute and wasn't successful and these are the jokes that I
think people should be doing.
Did you guys see that thing with Jim Norton was on with that,
that blogger person,
I was just fucking was hilarious.
She was saying that comedy clubs were filled.
We're basements filled with angry men and she was coming off is quite angry
herself.
The whole thing was fucking hilarious.
Uh,
and this is the thing about people who get offended by comedy.
I want to see somebody get outside of their own box.
You know,
I want to see the fat person in the crowd get offended by,
I don't know.
I Dunno what,
pick a topic,
a different topic.
I'm trying to think.
Okay.
A fat guy get offended by misogynistic,
uh,
material.
Have the dog lover,
the Peta person get offended by fucking,
uh,
I don't know the rape jokes or whatever.
Whatever the fucking Joe gives a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Who goes to a comedy club and takes joke seriously,
especially as a standup comedian.
You know what I mean?
I just,
for the life of me,
I'll never fucking understand that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I had the right,
when I came up to fucking talk about whatever I want to talk about and I failed
miserably and I flailed and I made big mistakes and I offended people in the
crowd and all of that fucking shit.
But that was all part of learning to become a comic.
Okay.
Finding what it is you're supposed to be doing on stage is part of the learning
process.
So to try and fucking just cut that off.
I Dunno.
I think it was really just a publicity stunt.
You know,
when you write an open letter to white male comics right there,
how hard,
how much harder could you be trying to be like a lightening rod?
Um,
I don't know.
I don't fucking get done.
Hey,
I played guitar for like six,
seven years and I'm offended by the cords.
Eric Clapton is using it.
Okay.
And if you're listening to this,
you're angry blog or I'm just fucking around.
It's just jokes before you get your fucking panties and a God damn bunch again,
but maybe that's what you should do.
And then you can get on another talk show and discuss comedy.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
By the way,
I thought Jim was great on it.
I thought he was fucking,
I thought it was tremendous.
All right,
there we go.
What else am I talking about here?
Um,
you know,
I sold lemonade,
street side for like three weeks when I was a kid.
And um,
I would like to talk to the people that Lipton ice tea about some of the things
that they're doing with their ice tea and lemonade.
You know,
I don't like the Arnold Palmer.
I feel that they should be separate.
All right.
I'm sorry,
what am I talking about here?
Let's get back to the podcast.
All right.
Can we do that bill for the love of fucking God?
Oh my apologies to the Chicago Blackhawks by the way.
Okay.
My apologies to the Chicago Blackhawks.
I thought the La Kings,
we're going to beat you guys.
I really did.
My Damn dammit.
I'm like,
don't even act like he didn't age during both of those games since the last time
I said that.
And I got to tell you a lot of Blackhawk fans really confident talking a lot of
shit on my Twitter.
It's almost as if the Bruins didn't just sweep the fucking Pittsburgh penguins.
Yeah,
I guess that doesn't mean anything to them.
I'm impressed with the way that they beat the La Kings.
Evidently they're not too impressed with sweeping the Pittsburgh Penguins.
And by the way,
did anybody watch,
uh,
the,
um,
after the Bruins one,
did anybody watch,
uh,
the Sidney Crosby press conference?
That dude would not give it up to the broads on any fucking level whatsoever.
They'll be like,
you know,
you were held scoreless you had zero points through four games in a playoff
game.
That's never happened.
You ever in the history of your being the Wayne Gretzky of right now,
why do you think that was?
And he's just like,
I dunno,
you know,
uh,
I don't know.
It was weird.
It was like a,
you know,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
They go,
do you think it was the goal tending on the other team?
He's like,
Nah,
I wasn't it.
Yeah,
I don't think so on wasn't the,
uh,
goaltender we had our opportunities and uh,
just wouldn't go in.
What do you think?
Because maybe they blocked the shots and they were playing great.
Nah,
that wasn't that one that either.
Then what was it Sydney actually respected or on some level that he was such a
competitor that he was still competing with the Bruins even though the series
was over,
he just would not give them credit on any fucking level.
Okay.
For completely disrupting his game,
four straight games in a row,
you know,
I mean,
I'm
okay.
Look,
I was as dumbfounded as anybody that we swept them,
but I mean I didn't have any questions at the end.
The answers to all of those questions was sitting on the other bench and uh,
and he didn't give it up.
They didn't give it up.
But you know what do,
by the way,
how many teeth did that guy fucking lose?
Man?
Holy Shit.
That guy is like,
what is that?
That was one to 16 up top.
17 to 32 on the bottom.
Halfway between 17 and 32 we'll say that's like numbers 25 he lost like teeth
number 25 26 27
in at least 28 if not 29.
He's lost either four or five fucking teeth right down the bottom.
Man.
Jesus.
Did you guys ever see that?
Like you want to talk how tough hockey players are and I include Sidney Crosby
and as much as I call them,
the pouty lips,
Cub Scout,
that fucking dude took us slot.
Somebody,
I forget,
I can't remember who the puck deflected off somebody stick and caught him right
in the fucking face,
broke his jaw and knocked out.
It looks anywhere from three to five teeth.
They literally flew out of his mouth
and the fucking dude gets up in skates off the ice with the trainers and uh,
you know,
I guarantee you within five days he was skating again.
I don't know,
I could never do that.
So anyways,
so here we are,
the original six,
the original six or in the Stanley Cup,
we've got an original six for the first time since 1979 when the Montreal
Canadian French were playing,
uh,
the,
the New York Rangers.
Um,
so I'm really excited about that.
This is great for hockey and I think it's going to be a great series.
And,
uh,
you know,
I actually watched those last two games and uh,
I want,
see if Brian Billick in loot in Milan,
Lou Cheech around on the ice at the same time,
that's going to be fucking unbelievable because those are two of the biggest
dudes in the league.
And uh,
it's,
I think it's going to be a fucking awesome series and I hope it doesn't go six.
I want this thing to go seven.
I hope it's going to be a classic.
Like I said,
the NHL is going to be on the cover and the NHL playoffs are on the cover of
sports illustrated under the headline the best and it should just a great time
for hockey.
And if they had this a great,
you know,
Stanley Cup final,
maybe they'll get a little more respect and uh,
and obviously of course I want my Bruins to win and I'm thinking about going to
a game.
I might go in Chicago.
You know,
I already went to a playoff game when I was back in Boston and plus I love those
Chicago Jerseys,
the red ones.
I think it was one of my favorite ones in the league.
And I want to go there and a,
and I won't be a cunt.
I'm not going to show with my Bruins shit.
I'm just going to sit there stoically and,
uh,
when the Bruins score and hopefully win the fucking gate,
you know,
I won't do anything to get the shit kicked out of me.
And I'll go back to my rented fucking Chevy Malibu and I'll drive back to
fucking O'Hare and that'll be it.
And I'll have that experience.
Speaking of experiences,
it is my birthday,
everybody,
and I want to thank everyone who wished,
wished me a happy birthday.
And,
uh,
what was I gonna say?
Yeah.
People are,
uh,
you know,
my friends and family and life were asking me,
you know what I wanted for my birthday and I told all of them,
nothing.
Look at me.
Don't buy me anything.
Just like Jimmy and,
uh,
in Goodfellas.
All right.
I've learned something through the water damage that I had in my house when I
took everything out of my fucking closets in these couple of,
I have so much fucking shit that I have not used or even looked at in,
in years.
And uh,
I already gave away my Fran Tarkington Jersey.
I know some people were asking whether it was still available.
I gave that away and I gave it away to the first guy.
Um,
I read like I read like 20 emails before I got to this guy and he actually
brought up like Alan Page,
Jim Marshall,
Carl Eller,
Paul Krauss,
Chuck Foreman,
Fred Cox,
right back when men one named after Dicks,
you know,
and um,
he knew all that shit.
So I said,
fuck it.
I'll give it to it to give it to that person.
Um,
and if the person who as it is listening,
please take a picture yourself in the Jersey sent it to me.
I'll put it up on the podcast page if you want.
If you want a little,
a little fucking shout out or an,
and actually will stop people from suggesting that.
I would say that there's a giveaway when there is no giveaway.
So anyways,
um,
yeah,
I don't want any more shit.
I'm not buying any more sports tee shirts because I get sentimental value and I
can't fucking throw him out.
And uh,
from here on out,
I'm just buying those Malcolm young solid color fucking tee shirts.
And when they wear out,
I throw him out cause they don't mean shit to me.
And uh,
no,
I got to do it,
man.
I gotta fucking get rid of all my God damn shit.
So today what I'm doing for my birthday is I think I'm going to go to the gun
range and I'm going to go drive out into the desert.
One of the other,
um,
one or the other.
I don't know if I'm going to go over the,
I usually go over the gun range or somebody knows what the fuck they're doing,
like going over there by myself and just renting a gun.
But I gotta tell you,
it's oddly fucking relaxing.
Who's kitten Ho.
I'm 45 fucking years old.
What?
I'm not going to do shit for my birthday.
All right.
I'm doing my God damn podcasts and I might go drive out to the desert cause I
just want,
I always wanted to do that because I'm a nerd.
All right,
that's it.
Okay,
so here we go.
Here's the,
uh,
here's some questions for this week.
Um,
oh,
casino carpets.
It says part three.
The final answer.
I was just like a trilogy,
like one of those spaces.
You know what?
No,
I feel bad that I fucking came down on that girl who was fucking blogging and
the shit call in our failed comic.
Like,
I fucking know.
You know what it is.
If she's still fucking listening,
if somebody gives her this part of it,
you know what it really is,
is
I just can't believe a fellow comic would fucking attack.
I just didn't criticize it
with,
with that angle,
you know what I mean?
To shrink it down and make it smaller.
Okay.
I just,
it just blows my fucking mind.
I'm just disappointed.
Yeah.
Disappointed,
I guess is more the word.
The Shit I said before I set out a fucking anger.
I didn't mean that shit,
but it's just fucking
okay.
You know what I mean?
I've been doing this shit 21 years and I'm still learning stuff.
I don't know shit about the yard.
Why?
There's no fucking way I would go on television and start.
Okay.
You know,
criticizing other fucking calm and not to mention like this whole fucking thing,
like there's all these rape jokes being told is just so fucking inaccurate.
Like you just walk into a comedy club in,
everyone's rang,
her rang,
rang rape,
rape.
I,
I'm trying to think,
the only person I can actually think of,
okay.
The Raleigh rape joke that I,
that really stands out that I remember was Jim Norton.
He did a,
he did a hilarious one.
He was talking about going to prison in some,
he said,
Jim,
would you,
uh,
you think you'd get raped if you went to prison?
He goes,
he goes,
look at me.
I would get raped on the bus ride on in the way into prison or something like
that.
I butchered the joke
and it was funny.
So I don't know.
I just think,
you know,
the last thing stand up needs is for fellow comics to be fucking trying to mold
it into what the fuck they is an individual think it should be that just,
that's just beyond me.
Why did I get into this shit?
I don't fucking know.
You know why?
Because it bugs me.
All right,
here we go.
Casino carpets,
part three.
The final answer.
Bill Ewm Wallace,
I installed carpet for six years.
That guy was only half right.
Oh,
that,
that was the guy last week who claimed that the carpeting is actually really
expensive and it's a really high quality and uh,
so I guess it's easier to clean or set came with the fuck he said.
Jesus Christ.
He said yes.
The casino carpets are a commercial grade carpet.
Yes,
they last a long time.
Um,
but they aren't crazy colors and designs because it makes the carpets last
longer.
The colors and design are a to hide stains.
When you spill a big strawberry Margarita on a solid blue carpet stain will be
playing his day with wacky designs and colors.
You can't spot a spilled drink.
Oh,
cool.
Be,
it hides the seams of the carpet.
Carpet comes in 12 or 15 foot wide rolls.
Commercial carpets are usually 15.
That means for every 15 feet in with you,
we'll have a full scene.
Uh,
it was a solid color.
You would see a straight line in the carpet for the entire length of the room.
The colors and design breaks up to seem like camouflage.
Well,
there you go.
Love the podcast.
Come to Tulsa sometime and go fuck yourself.
Oh,
thank you.
Um,
I am coming to Tulsa on the Billy red state tour.
All right.
X Defense Minister from Canada speaks out about,
speaks,
speaks about,
okay.
See,
this is what not,
once again,
not my fault,
this person writes x,
defense minister from Canada speaks about out about aliens,
out about aliens or speaks out about aliens or does he speak about out about
aliens?
See what I'm saying?
Susan always me.
All right.
Bill loved the podcast.
Freelance every week.
Uh,
they're much appreciated,
Yada,
Yada.
I thought you might like this link as you're a big conspiracy theory of big
conspiracy theorist.
You mean?
He said,
it's the former Canadian defense administrator.
No Canadian defense minister giving some bold claims about several species of
aliens living among us and actually working with elements and the government.
Uh,
not only that,
but a shadowy
cabal.
Ca Bal cable cable,
I dunno,
comprised of the council on Foreign Relations,
the bill,
the Burgers,
the tea
trilateral commission.
That should add a hyphen in it.
You can't,
the international banking cartel,
uh,
the oil cartels,
members of various intelligence organizes and select members and military judge
[inaudible] one world government.
Check it out,
sir.
The last thing I'm going to do is look at this.
I'll put the link up there.
Ah,
fuck it.
I'll look at it right now.
This shit just freaks me out and makes me depressed because there's nothing I
can do about it.
Okay.
Now,
well,
how is this going to help me,
sir?
If I find out there's actually aliens living among us,
talking to international bankers,
you know,
am I going to come walking in,
bursting into their meeting like the end of a feel good movie?
You know,
like,
hey man,
the people have spoken and they liked me.
All right,
here we go.
I got it right here.
Uh,
Canada's former minister of national defense,
Paul Haler testifies at the citizen's hearing on disclosure,
where the fuck am I last month in Washington DC that aliens are living among us
and that it is likely at least two of them are working with the u s government.
Oh,
this guy sounds like he's out of his fucking mind.
Ugh.
Let,
let's,
let's kind of flip the script here.
Let's say you're an alien.
Okay.
All right.
Whoever's listening to this still who believes in aliens who isn't blogging
about my reaction to the blogger?
Um,
okay.
Can you go to what you go to another fucking solar system now,
the galaxy,
whatever the fucking terminology is,
and you land there.
Okay,
what are you going to do other than try and get blended it.
Blend in so people don't chop your fucking alien head off.
Like,
how exactly did this fucking alien?
Okay.
Get,
infiltrate the government.
This is like Mr. Smith goes to Washington,
the alien just lands and just goes,
okay.
Ah Right.
I mean,
how come he didn't do this in Argentina?
We picked the United States,
goes right into fucking Washington DC walks into the Capitol building is
somebody filibustering so they can't make an electric car or whatever comes
right out on the house floor and then does what?
Okay.
You know,
security comes up,
tries to shoot him and he just puts his hands up and their guns turned into like
chocolate bars or fall to the ground.
Yeah.
And then for some reason everybody in their suits doesn't scrambled and freak
the fuck out,
you know?
No,
you just fucking walk out there today.
Let's go and I'll relax,
relax,
relax.
A simple technology that you guys will discover if you become friends with me,
hired attorney,
the fucking gone into some melted shit that a,
doesn't let people shoot you.
I am from the planet.
Zoll Tar.
Right.
It always begins with a z.
How does that work?
Like if you were a fucking alien and you went to another God damn planet.
Exactly.
I guess.
Okay.
You'd be like,
all right,
if there's a bunch of different nations,
which one seems to be running?
Shit,
I got to chop the head off and you're just going to want you when you were in a
buddy,
two of you
going to walk in fucking arm and arm.
Yeah.
And do what?
Hey,
listen.
I think just the simple fact that we were able to get here,
you know the kind of firepower that we're capable of.
Uh,
for some fucking reason we want to take over this planet or we want you guys to
do shit the way we feel that the it should be done.
Okay.
Who?
Who would want that fucking headache?
I don't,
I don't know that I believe this shit anyways.
He believes hell.
Whose beliefs on extra life?
Extra terrestrial life.
And you are so your foes are well established.
Made the statements at the nongovernmental hearings chaired by six form a US
calm congressmen and aimed at,
according to the events website,
doing what the u s congress had failed to do for 45 years.
Seek out the facts surrounding the most important issue of this or any other
time evidence pointing towards an extraterrestrial presence.
Engaging the human race.
Yeah.
All right.
You know what?
Even I have my limits when it comes to that type of shit.
All right.
I don't think that's the most pressing thing.
I would say.
Yeah,
I was fucking up the environment,
world population and that type of shit.
Shit,
it's a little more
okay.
Unless you want to throw more people from other galaxies.
Also living here,
do they drink bottled water too?
Here we go.
People Eve Voice,
right?
He voices.
The reason why you're going to make more money in 2013 when your customers call,
you have your own toll free number,
professional grading,
dial by number,
name directory,
and more.
You'll sound like a fortune five company even though you still in your cubicle
and blow away your competitors' Eve voice.
Let you give out one number that rings wherever you are.
The beach,
the bar matter.
You sound
like you're at the office.
He got to go to [inaudible] dot com and use the Promo Code Bill.
He voice even takes all your voicemails,
transcribes them and sends them to you instantly as a text or an email so you
can check voicemails before the meeting ends and not look rude.
He voice is only 10 bucks a month right now.
Listening to my podcast,
you can get a free trial of a voice for 30 days.
Stop what you're doing.
Hit Pause,
stop listening to this podcast right now.
Set up your eve voice and free trial and uh,
see what I'm talking about.
It's a great way to support my podcast and an easy way to make more money this
year.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's easy.
voice.com Promo Code Bill,
or just go to the podcast page on bill bird.com and click on the voice banner
right now.
Okay,
the man,
great system.
Everybody this father's Day,
I think the man great.
What does the man great us?
They are 100% made in America.
Cast iron grilling grades that are revolutionizing the way people grill heavy
duty grilling greats.
Deliver exactly what you need to achieve that perfect steak house flavor,
chicken,
steak or veggies.
We'll never have tasted so good.
No more flareups,
no more dry meat.
Guaranteed named one of 2012 best grilling accessories by men's health magazine.
Man,
greats are the perfect gift for dad this father's Day.
How do you get them?
Well,
you go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Coupon Code [inaudible],
B U R R for their 1999 father's day special or click the man great banner on the
and the show website.
Sorry,
100% made in America.
Cast iron hundred percent steakhouse quality grilling in your backyard.
Remember each Monday morning podcast or to comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush.
Again,
that's the man.
Great Grill enhancement system.
Order today,
man,
great.com man gray truck.com and enter the coupon code [inaudible] at the
checkout.
And last but certainly not least,
legal zoom America was built by innovators and dreamers.
People like Nicola Tesla,
Preston Tucker,
and Thomas crapper.
But it's the inventors and entrepreneurs all around us.
People like you that make America is such a great country.
This month.
Legal zoom.com celebrates in innovators,
inventions and people who want to get out of their jobs by helping you launch
your own dream.
Apply for a patent to sus to secure your invention.
Hang in there,
Bill.
You can do it.
A register your trademark to protect your product and services.
Incorporate or form an LLC and launch your business dream.
Just call or visit legal zoom.com and they'll take care of you from start to
finish.
They've already helped about a million businesses get started,
right.
Celebrate and innovations with legal zoom and for a limited time,
get a special price on trademark,
copyright,
and patent applications by using the referral code bur bur are at checkout.
Protect your creations and launch your dream@legalzoom.com legal zoom can
provide self help services at your specific direction or they can connect you to
an attorney.
Uh,
but they're not a law firm.
Don't forget to use that referral code.
Burb B.
U.
R.
All right,
there you go.
Here we are winding down the final minutes
of the podcast.
Let me close this right here.
I don't want to save that.
Uh,
fuck.
This happens every God damn week older.
All right,
here we go.
Next letter.
This letter is about an older lady.
Um,
I'm a 29 year old guy and for the last two years I have been seeing an
incredible,
incredibly amazing woman that is 13 years older than me.
And you know what?
It's not going to work out,
sir,
cause you're 29 and she's fucking 42.
You know,
that doesn't seem to work out.
Women can do that.
For some reason they could do it.
You know,
didn't you learn anything with Ashton Kutcher and ain't going to happen.
when you're 37,
she's going to be 50.
Come on
37.
You could still pull a 27 year old.
You're coming home to her,
right?
She's starting to get hot flashes.
She's taken Geritol.
I mean this is not going to work.
I'm sorry.
Let me continue.
She's sexy,
fun and we share a lot of common interests.
We talked about what direction our relationship was going to take very early on
and we decided that keeping it casual was the way to go.
Smart move.
Now what does taking a casual meet that means I fuck you once every six weeks in
my birthday and my birthday and my,
my,
why did I say birthday in my book?
You know what it is.
It's my birthday.
I don't want to get on with it.
I want to go drive out to the desert.
That's what it was.
Uh,
we didn't commit to each other in any official sense,
but neither of us saw anyone else.
Well,
Jesus Christ,
now you're gonna catch feelings for over the two years.
I fell in love with her they ago and wanted to commit so we could make a real go
of it.
I fucked up though.
I never confessed those feelings to her.
I was afraid of things eventually hitting a wall because of the age difference.
So I felt safe or not telling her.
She recently told me she had has wanted the same things I do this whole time,
but she has now met someone closer to her own age promising the real
relationship.
I never gave her.
I believe she has feelings for me but thanks.
This is the best choice for her.
What do I do?
Do I stand up and fight for what I want?
Consequences be damned or should I let her go and accept that age differences in
an insurmountable problem.
On a side note,
I've been in many relationships.
I know myself well enough to know the difference between love and infatuation.
Well then if you know the difference,
I would go for what you want.
Okay.
As an outsider I would say let her go.
MMM.
And even though you know the difference between love and infatuation,
do you want to have a family sir?
Okay.
You know,
cause if you,
you need to marry this girl
in a week and start pumping out the fucking kids cause she's already 42 are you
ready to do that?
Because if you're not,
you got to let her go.
All right.
That's all I got to say.
I'm sorry.
That's all I got on that one.
All right,
wife,
not down with the,
with the with nose job wife not down with nose job.
All right,
dear Billy boy loved the podcast.
I'll just stand up.
Thanks for that.
Well,
you're welcome.
Thank you for,
uh,
thank you for typing that.
Um,
he goes,
I'm a 31 year old guy.
I'm happily married to a usually supportive wife.
I never been too much of a self conscious person,
but ever since I was a teenager,
if there was one thing I could change about my physical appearance,
that would be my nose.
It's a little big and has a bump on the ridge I have now.
Okay.
He said ref referenced a profile on Nikolai Tesla
or the rule of Constantine to get the idea.
Obviously a giant knows what the SIF with severe acne was.
Immediate fuel for insult through junior high school for the hordes of 14 year
olds.
I vowed that one day.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I am just the fucking worst year.
I vowed that one day I would get a nose job to boost my self esteem.
Well I am now in a position where I can pay to have the surgery.
Um,
I used to ask my wife a few years back what she thought about it and she said
that if it makes me happy than do it.
However,
now that I am closer to having one having it done,
she seems to have changed her mind.
She says that she couldn't,
she couldn't get used to seeing me look different and isn't sure if she'll like
the uh,
the way the remodeled me looks,
I'm disappointed because I really want to have it done and what she would be
supportive.
The thing is my wife is a self conscious person and I'm worried that on a small
level she thinks that the new me will be more attractive and warrant the
attention of more females.
This is not what I'm,
this is not why I'm doing this.
I just want to feel better about myself.
What should I do?
Thanks for your help.
All right.
Back up for a second.
You said your wife has self conscious and you're worried that on a small level
she thinks the new me will be more attractive and warrant the attention of more
females.
As much as you say,
this isn't why you're doing this.
I think that's why you're doing it subconsciously,
you know,
I think that that's your thought and you're putting it on your wife.
You have to understand,
yeah,
you gotta understand this.
All right.
Your nose.
That's like the,
uh,
that's the Hubby of face.
Okay.
If you add or subtract to that,
you're really changing what you look like.
Okay.
And every checkout,
they're so dirty dancing and they all sell at the lead of that movie.
Did she got a nose job?
And I thought she was fucking adorable in that movie.
I thought she was beautiful.
You know,
I never,
I could never get through the fucking movie,
but,
uh,
I thought she was hot and then she got a nose job and I,
it was like,
ah,
what did you do?
You know?
Look Dude,
you're fucking nose makes you unique.
That's why you should stick with it.
Stay with it.
I mean,
I dunno
to get a nose job because people teased you when you were 14.
You better than that.
All right.
And you with your wife,
she loves you for who you are.
You know,
I
listen to,
I mean,
it's your,
it's your call in the end,
but they don't exactly have those things down to a science,
you know what I mean?
At this point,
plastic surgery,
it's like shooting threes.
You know,
most of them.
Uh,
and most of them don't go in,
but when they do,
the crowd goes crazy.
So there's a chance that you could come out with the nose you want,
but more times than not,
I think it's going to,
if you know you want your nose to fucking clang off the front of the rim,
or even worse,
shoot a fucking air ball splat on the fucking hardwood.
Um,
I would never recommend plastic surgery,
but dude,
I know what you're a,
I know what you're going through.
This shit about myself.
I don't like that.
I'm fucking losing my hair.
And believe me,
every time those hair commercials come on,
I fucking sit there and look at them and go,
should I,
should I?
And then I always say I'm not gonna but I never rule it out that I wouldn't do
it.
I just keep waiting because every five years it gets better and better and
better.
Like how it looks at this point now they can just vacuum the hair out of the
back and just fucking planet upfront.
Um,
as opposed to having the scars and the hair plugs and having that shit.
But I still,
for some reason I'm not going to do it.
Uh,
I dunno why and I don't know why
I think about it cause I think like,
I can guarantee you this,
if women went bald,
they would all get fucking hair.
They would all have hair plugs in one generation and then they would all have
that type of thing.
And I always makes me laugh when women make fun of guys that get like a hair
transplant,
like,
oh my God,
it's,
they sit,
they're wearing makeup,
you know,
high heels on and everything about them is to fucking enhance,
they're looks.
Um,
but then also I get why they don't like it,
you know?
Cause I think what they're attracted to is different.
Obviously they don't want to have some troll of a man,
but,
uh,
I think that they,
they made sure this might come back to you.
They want you to be a fucking man and be comfortable with yourself.
Go out there and just swing a goddamn acts and bring some fucking lumbering for
the fire.
You know,
they don't want to just sit there watching you,
looking at yourself in the mirror.
Go on and look at this.
Look at my nose.
I just don't like why my ears look,
you know,
I dunno.
I this,
this,
my advice would be,
I would think long and fucking hard.
All right.
And you told me to look at that picture of like Tesla and Constantine over the
fuck you say their names.
Uh,
why don't you go look up that chick before and after who was in a dirty dancing,
which is an asshole thing for me to do.
Cause I'm sure she had a lot of trauma over that.
Now I'm going to fucking restir the pot.
Uh,
but yeah,
and then you,
you'll probably be like,
well that was a nose job from fucking 23 years ago and I feel like rolling the
dice then by all means go for it.
But uh,
why don't you do it before and after.
Take a picture,
you know,
standing to the side,
like the Mug Mug shot photo,
give me a forward and to the side and then forward to the side in the end.
And this is the deal.
If you get me a before and I never get an after,
then I know what happened.
I'm trying to think what was one of the songs from dirty dancing
was that,
that [inaudible] that all dad stay with her drinks were hazy.
He has really tight slacks.
Okay.
And his hair is done better then mine,
um,
Outros Howard core was Patrick Swayze,
the guy had cancer.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm still smoking.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That dude,
when I like a man,
you know,
he really did.
So did she sit down with same to take a total lefthand turn.
All right.
I can tell you right now,
people are about ready to hang me.
All right?
And I was rough.
I would definitely accept the hood.
Please put the hood off my face.
You can't see me blubbering inside of it.
He said,
no,
I don't want the hood.
The stare down,
everybody was talking shit.
F Fuck you go fuck yourself.
Your mother's a whore.
And they put the rope around his neck and furthermore,
I said,
your grandmother's mother's a cunt.
I spit on your wall and that was it.
Okay.
Um,
all right,
outros.
Oh,
here's the outros here.
All right.
I guess the show was over once again,
everybody,
a couple of things.
If you'd like to buy a hard copy version of my DVD for you,
old school people,
you can now do that@billbird.com.
You can also download it,
um,
or you can come out to one of my shows and I'll autograph it for you.
Uh,
yeah,
and if you'd like to donate to this podcast and the wounded warrior project,
go to amazon.com no,
go to the amazon.com banner on the podcast page of my website.
Click on the son of a bitch.
Go to Amazon,
buy whatever the hell you want.
Doesn't change the price.
They kicked me a little.
Uh,
thanks to sending them here.
And then I pass it on some of it,
10% of it,
John to the wounded warriors project.
All right,
so that's it.
Okay.
Now that the show's over,
don't forget us to,
uh,
support our sponsors.
Go to,
uh,
go to,
set up the free trial of he voice.
Join thousands of entrepreneurs who use their EAV voice,
personal receptionist 24,
seven right now.
Get a voice for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] Com Promo Code Bill.
That's a voice.com.
Promocode Bell,
um,
and Hulu plus,
as I mentioned,
start watching TV,
your favorite shows right now.
Go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com Click on the Hulu plus banner
free,
extended free trial or Hulu plus.com/bill and finally sign up for dollar shave
club.
Forward Slash burr makes a great father's day gift.
You get high quality raises,
Cynthia door every month for a fraction of the cost.
Um,
and that is it,
ladies and gentlemen,
that is it.
That is a podcast for this week.
Please watch the Stanley Cup finals if you get a chance.
Also,
I'm rooting for the sparse.
I'm rooting for the spurs against the Miami Heat.
I'm doing that.
He got to do it.
Okay,
you got to do it.
Fundamental basketball.
You know,
every white guy wants that to win.
Get Out.
Cause that's the best we can bring fundamental basketball.
There's never been a white doctor Jay.
It just has it.
You know,
there's been some white guys we can grow.
Afros has been a grant.
A couple of white guys that you know,
can jump a little bit,
but it's just,
you know,
we're picking roll guys.
So,
um,
who knows.
I don't know what's going to happen.
Uh,
I think the inevitable,
but I'm hoping the spurs are gonna win.
Um,
and not even just cause that's silly shit that I was just saying about white guy
basketball.
I just love,
you know,
you got to love when the underdog wins and speaking of which the Bruins,
it got to be the underdog against the,
uh,
the black cocks considering the first two games are in Chicago.
Isn't that right?
Um,
who knows.
Check it out or go check out sports illustrated.
Read up on some hockey can maybe can get involved in this series.
It's a great game.
That's it.
That's the podcasts.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.